c'est du grand déballage à l'américaine
où elle va jusqu'à raconter la taille du
pénis de Donald Trump qu'elle compare à
un champignon manifestement plutôt un
petit champignon qu'un gros champignon
et elle vend aussi sur Internet elles
vont aussi sur Internet
popo le jeune papa est relégué dans un
enclos et il semble avoir quelques
conflits de voisinage
je te supporte pas
de l'autre côté du mur l'outil une
femelle qui n'a pas accepté les avances
du mastodonte
cela me brise le coeur comment vous
sentez-vous c'est horrible c'est fou je
suis inquiet pour lui je suis inquiet
pour nous je suis inquiet pour le pays
que Dieu sauve le président Trump la
guerre et donc déclaré entre Donald
Trump et stormy Daniels
aujourd'hui parle de stormy Daniel's
une victime de violence mais bon je me
suis retrouvé quand même avec des bleus
des cocards des côtes
en bas de chez lui
[Musique]
pour leur frapper bien sûr
si on voit la femelle comment ça à
s'attaquer au mal faut vite les séparer
parce que en fait elle cherchait à le
tuer il passe simplement à se défendre
jusqu'à la mort Flora et Jérôme ont déjà
secouru des mâles en très mauvaise
posture on a un la semaine dernière qui
s'est fait barrage une testicule par sa
femelle donc lui il est parti direct au
vétérinaire pour se faire offrir
ça va pas du tout ça ben non mais j'ai
mis deux secondes dans le pousser en
fait tu m'attends pour qu'on déplace le
frigo ensemble mais je l'ai fait toute
seule quoi je peux le faire
[Musique]
astronaute c'est plutôt fille ou plutôt
garçon ou un garçon
moi aussi
[Musique]
papa papa
maman maman c'est plutôt la femme de
ménage qui le fait il y a une phrase
typique à Naples
moi je m'approche doucement je la
regarde dans les yeux et je lui dis
beauté
tu es une étoile qui brille pas mais qui
est un selfie avec cette phrase c'est
dans la poche
aucune chance je te promets
les mâles sont ma foi bien installés
c'est confortable
[Musique]
on sait pas trop ce que pense aucun
signe de plaisir spécifique
[Musique]
alors que lui oui c'est c'est très clair
tu veux ou tu veux pas
tu le sais bien si tu veux
[Musique]
pas j'entrais pas une maladie
oui mais voilà réponds-moi non ou bien
oui c'est comme ça si ou comme ça où tu
veux ou tu veux pas tu veux ou tu veux
pas vous avez déjà violé des femmes
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu envie de
violer une femme
oui une certaine façon
est-ce que tous les hommes sont des
violeurs en puissance
c'est possible
mais pas ce soir
alors je suis contente de pas être le
plus vieux mais si on devient de plus en
plus drôle en vieillissant vive les
vieux
on meurt toujours du sida
[Musique]
650 000 morts dans le monde en 2021 un
million et demi de nouvelles
contaminations
dont 160 000 enfants
ces chiffres sont vertigineux
il nous faut sortir de cette enfer et
croyez-moi nous allons y arriver il a
donc convaincu sa fille qu'il fallait
effectivement faire très très attention
et se protéger et j'ai lu qu'elle avait
répondu sa fille dans cette personne qui
est ici
et qu'elle avait répondu mais ça oui
effectivement il fallait se protéger
mais toujours une capote qui m'a dit oh
j'en ai bouffé du plastoc c'est pas moi
qui l'ai inventé quand même
vous avez répondu ça à votre père alors
faut porter plainte contre le
journaliste
pas un centime n'est perdu
sans vaut donc plus rien n'est possible
je vous remercie infiniment de faire le
samedi
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce qui se passe quand on est vous
voulez trop chaud
on sait s'amuser c'est tout c'est la
chenille la chenille qui redémarre c'est
la chose
phare et accident de voiture est-ce que
vous pensez à votre film avec le
Palmashow ou au fait qu'en ce moment
pour Palmade c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est vraiment dû au stress
parce que j'ai senti quand même une
grosse solidité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus ça sera facile pour toi en plus je
crois que physiquement j'ai jamais été
aussi au top et ça c'est personnellement
quelque chose je pense que honnêtement
si quelqu'un aux États-Unis tombait sauf
si bien alors
c'était chouette d'être avec vous j'aime
bien cette expression c'était chouette
vraiment sympa ou alors vous voulez
démarrer cette émission en ayant une
pensée pour Huguette de scènes de ménage
au revoir madame Marion GAB